my name is Bailey Arlen cows and I'm  from Houston Texas in 2012 i graduated  from Clements high school in Sugar Land  Texas currently I am a Spanish and  political economy major at hillsdale  college in michigan in this spring I  have the privilege of interning at the  Heritage Foundation the Washington  Hillsdale internship program we call  whip for short we bring anywhere between  10 to 20 students a semester out to DC  they take two or three classes and they  in turn on the hill at the Heritage  Foundation really anywhere they want to  we find somebody coming out of college  who has some practical real-world  experience especially experience that  applies to what we do it really sets  them apart Washington is one of those  places that kids can learn a lot and  gain a lot just from being here for a  few months and that sense coming here  and having that internship experience i  can guarantee will be life-changing  you